okay let's talk about the wall
the wall is a multimedia project created
by english rock band pink floyd
consisting of a 1979 studio album
a live performance touring over 1980 and
81
a 1982 experimental film a 2010 through
2013 revival tour
a 2015 concert film and a 2016 opera
the plot of all the various adaptations
center around a rock star named pink who
struggles with depression and substance
abuse
in the midst of an emotional spiral pink
reflects on slash hallucinates the
events of his life that have led to that
point
including vivid fabrication of the death
of his father in world war
ii hazy memories of the blitz his
relationship with his mother creative
dissatisfaction a decaying marriage
and a job in the music industry where he
is treated as a commodity to be used
all of which form the metaphorical
bricks in the emotional wall that pink
uses to separate himself from the world
i want to focus in mostly on the 1982
film because it is
i think the adaptation that is able to
do the most with the concept
the film was written by pink floyd
frontman roger waters directed by alan
parker with animation by gerald scarf
and it is
well it's a pretty heavy film it can be
a hard watch it comes from a very dark
place
emotionally speaking there is a lot of
disturbing imagery
it's a very angry film
it's pretty abstract in his presentation
relying heavily on associative imagery
rather than conventional narrative
and this is both a strength and a
weakness of the film
abstraction is counter-intuitively
very efficient it allows a movie to be
about a lot of things simultaneously by
letting
symbols bleed into one another the movie
pinballs between war
classism police brutality the
criminalization of youth culture
thatcherism generational trauma
commodification of art
and the homegrown fascism of the nations
that bragged about beating the nazis
and it's able to do this pretty fluidly
the film's underlying anger is true to
form
often incoherent struggling to vocalize
and manifest the
exact shape of the subject falling back
on abstract imagery
in order to suggest an emotional truth
where literalism is
insufficient this allows the film to
create
really powerful moments a running motif
is anti-war
expressed as a seething rage of betrayal
abandonment and exploitation at the
hands of the system roger water's father
was a conscientious objector during
world war ii
a pacifist who drove ambulance during
the blitz in 1943
however he changed his mind and was
commissioned as a second lieutenant in
the territorial army
in september of that year he was dead
five months later
in goodbye blue skies the union jack
shatters into pieces
for all its bravado and bluster english
nationalism
is just blood in the gutter soldiers
sent to war don't
die for their country they just die
the boys beat the germans and came home
just in time to build atom bombs
symbols shift and merge and break apart
juxtaposed and contrasted in order to
create an impression of their
interconnected relationship
in a way that is difficult to do using
mere words
and core to the theme of the piece as a
whole no
one specific thing is the load-bearing
cause
there is no singular source of the
sickness in society that isolates us
from one another that suppresses us that
brutalizes us that exploits us
they are all just bricks in the wall
this
abstraction though can also work against
the film
a lot of the film's imagery almost 40
years later
has an almost juvenile makes you think
shallowness to it
worn down by a generation of trite
commentary on the relationship between
art and commerce
in no small part directly influenced by
the wall
that you know cheapens the wall simply
by association
the lack of a concise resolution the
lack of a clear point at the end
which functions for some viewers as a
powerfully disquieting denial of closure
also leaves the door open for symbols to
take on meanings
counter to their intended or desired use
a centerpiece moment in the film comes
when pink
suffering from an overdose is revived by
his manager and record industry flunkies
in order to be dressed and pushed out on
stage in this state pink
conceptualizes himself in an alter ego a
fascist
dictator indoctrinating teens primed by
a conformist education system
into hate and violence the sequence
spanning the songs in the flesh run like
hell and waiting for the worms
includes dramatization of hate crimes
and sexual assault
the film's imagery of crossed hammers
invented for the movie
as a deliberately unsettling expression
of contemporary fascism
and its ability to utilize the banal the
blunt the simplistic
was adopted in 1988 by actual neo-nazi
group the hammerskins
a now fractured organization whose
dispersed members
remain active in other hate
organizations to this day
the potent imagery structured as a
condemnation
was still adopted by people who saw the
violence not as horrifying
but as aspirational the character of
pink holds
fears and resentments towards women that
are emotionally challenging to watch
expressed on screen and while
a mature audience can certainly parse
the difference between a character's
excuses and reality
the film's lack of closure means there's
little guidance on what the audience is
ultimately meant to take away from the
depictions of pink being devoured by a
predatory vaginal flower
and part of that is rooted in the film's
emotional rawness the dark place of the
psyche where thoughts and fears and
beliefs are not rational but are deeply
potent and
extremely present pink intellectually
understands that his own
self-destruction and alienation
drove his wife away but emotionally
still conceptualizes her as a consuming
predator
it doesn't all make sense or resolve or
coalesce because
we don't all make sense everyone is the
illusion of order constructed
brick by brick out of chaos so while the
wall is
far from flawless and certainly not for
everyone there are still i feel
deep emotional truths in there a human
story about the contradiction of being
the self-amplifying spiral of isolation
and the fragility and hypocrisy of power
the album is good but it was always
written with a visual component in mind
be it the concert or the film
and i think the album definitely feels
less than
whole as a result the movie also adds
when the tigers broke free which is a
song that i think adds a lot of welcome
depth to the story
it's a really potent encapsulation of
how waters feels about the system that
killed his
took my father
from me
and this is a movie that doug walker a
man whose bread and butter
is getting irrationally angry at movies
for nine-year-olds
decided to riff in the form
of a parody recreation good old
pink floyd made a movie devoid
of even the slightest bitter subtlety
okay so what is this
why does this exist i'm going to have to
say
a bunch of unkind things and there's
really no
way around that because the observable
facts are just
prima facie unkind which maybe it's the
other way around i don't know i got a
high school educational
basically it's impossible to engage with
something like the wall even
sarcastically or disingenuously without
leaving a lot of yourself on the table
as a result
what you fixate on what you think is
silly why you think it's silly
these are all revealing and
that's not to say that you need to love
the wall or even
like the wall or you know you're a phony
or a poser or
shallow if you don't it's just that
defending that position is going to
demand
emotional honesty for most critics
that's not a problem
but we'll see
the nostalgia critic aka the critic aka
that guy with the glasses is the
brainchild of doug walker
an aspiring filmmaker from the suburbs
of chicago who in 2008 stumbled into an
early online video success with the then
nascent genre of angry reviews
the basic format more or less unchanged
in 13 years involves a recap of the plot
of a film
interspersed with one-liners and skits
usually with the comedy predicated on
slapstick reactions of either extreme
confusion
or extreme anger or both at 7 million
never leave the cave without it a bat
credit card they gave him a
bat credit card
they had the balls to give one of the
greatest superheroes of all time
a bat credit card in september 2019 they
published nostalgia critics the wall
a 40-minute musical review featuring
musician corey taylor his son griff
taylor and the collaborative works of
musician rob scallon and animator fenna
the reception was not good
all in all it's just not very funny
at all no exaggeration i'm not being
facetious i'm not trying to be a dick
this is the worst movie review i have
ever seen
when i first tried to watch doug
walker's the wall
um this is what happened to my computer
so clearly it was trying to protect me
this review has become somewhat
notorious online because there is
something deeply compelling about it
the arthouse ego trip had fallen
then slipped to the bargain bin for 393.
there is a tremendous amount of effort
on display but it's also
really lazy if that makes any sense the
priority really seems to be in doing
a lot doing everything rather than doing
any of it particularly well and this is
what's confusing
there's so much going on so many
collaborations
so many moving parts that it clearly
took
time and energy and passion an energy
and passion that
needs to be maintained on some level for
the weeks and weeks that it takes to put
all this together
but there's no evidence whatsoever
of what was actually driving that you
don't just
make something like this on accident in
an afternoon
this would have taken weeks if not
months to coordinate
the collaborations with satellite city
and rob scalin needed to be arranged
corey taylor and his son needed to come
out to chicago
the final version of the trial probably
took
80 hours just to render not even
including blocking and animating
then there's writing recording props
costumes
all of which you can cut a lot of
corners on
and make no mistake the corners here are
extremely cut
but there's a floor certain things are
still going to take
all week no matter how half you ask them
so on some level
you have to care you have to care
a lot to commit to this amount of work
and that passion you know it can come
from just really loving the wall
or just really hating the wall or
feeling like you have a lot of stuff to
say about it
but it's got to come from somewhere in
the middle doug does an ad for the
companion album that they were selling
for money that doug describes as a love
letter to pink floyd in their music
and it's just this is just such a love
letter
to pink floyd's music and the wall and
you can download the album
in the link below so hollow
as a pitch because the product the thing
that we're watching and listening to
the arthouse eco trip is extremely
clearly
not a love letter to pink floyd and is
dominated by someone who
based on the words being said doesn't
know much about pink floyd at all in the
first place
and really doesn't like what they do
know
them i don't even know
doug doesn't seem to understand the wall
on even a surface level
and really just doesn't appear
to care much about the wall one way or
another
sort of there is at no point any sense
that doug has
a personal relationship to the material
based off the depth of doug's commentary
it reads
very much like the opinion of someone
who watched the wall
for the first time after already
committing to do a full recreation
and then didn't particularly enjoy it
and wasn't really able to digest it
because the whole viewing went through
the filter of
looking for ideas for the recreation the
commentary
is extremely shallow while also being
deeply petty and mean but then also the
longer you go
into the review the further it drifts
from being about the wall
and the more it becomes a showcase for
doug's own
unrelated opinions there's no clear
sense of what viewpoints the various
characters are supposed to represent
the critic is used to voice multiple
different stances being both
critic audience surrogate creator
surrogate narrator and protagonist
but then all of those are caked in
various layers of sarcasm that make it
really difficult to parse what the
message is actually supposed to be
the whole of it is just very unclear the
commentary when it's not
completely off topic waffles between
faint praise
like well i guess the song is kind of
rad and really
performatively cruel stuff like calling
the creators clout chasing fakes
none of it feels like the kind of
good-natured ribbing you'd get from
actually invested fans who are making
fun of a thing that they love
what's missing at the core is any sense
of
motivation but that's it
we're stopping there well yeah the movie
did
i didn't even get a line hell i didn't
even sing a song
what'd you even think of the movie well
the movie ended on such an open
vagueness that only makes sense that the
review end on such an open vagueness
you get to the end and have no idea why
this was the form this product should
take why
make a straight reproduction of pretty
much 50 percent of the entire film
why make a complete companion album why
put
this much effort into a video about a
subject that you just
don't seem to have any substantive
opinions on at all
and why put all this effort into this
concept
for this specific movie i liked it fine
yeah me too a little full of itself but
good music and imagination
fair enough and having these questions
afterwards is
very bizarre when you're talking about a
review something that is
theoretically at least predicated
entirely on
you know talking about your opinions
and this is where we need to accept the
reality that this isn't really a review
it's not a parody it's not a commentary
and it's
not a spoof it's barely even about
the wall it's honestly closer to fan
fiction in a way
doug wants to be a filmmaker he wants to
make art but
he can't because he's a fundamentally
incurious person who
isn't much interested in what other
people think or feel and all his ideas
boil down to what if batman met mario
slapstick focuses on the most important
rule of comedy that all comedy in one
way or another
is based on misery
[Music]
with little to no dialogue quickly
identifiable characters and nothing but
chases people see it as classic because
it's so minimal and yet
so interesting it says so much with just
a few
clever choices fury road is the same way
he is youtube's own homegrown tommy
wiseau or neil breen
complete with the same unwillingness to
learn how a camera works
hey so you invited me up here what you
want to do just watch
tv you invited me up here to literally
watch tv
i'm a successful musician with millions
how can you expect me to be happy
it has that same heady mix of
incompetence and ego
that is absolutely intoxicating to talk
about
so much of the actual content is
predicated on readings of the material
that are just
wildly wrong and yet so absolutely
confident in their delivery doug decided
to accuse an 80-minute movie of being
too long and padded and then
didn't even flinch as he sandwiched that
between a rant about people being mean
to him on twitter
and an eight-minute argument with a
busty nightmare squirrel
and it's that element that deeply
misplaced sense of confidence that
really just makes nostalgic critics the
wall captivating
like the room it's a deeply cynical
product made by a fundamentally
untalented man
bored by the idea of personal growth
building so many layers of
self-protective irony
that it becomes unintentionally
revealing you mean like the room no
yes shut up doug is utilizing the wall
as a showcase for his own ideas his own
lyricism his own jokes his own singing
the video is him strutting his stuff as
a filmmaker
so while some of it is about the wall
for the most part the further you get
into it the more it shifts to just
being about doug this is a bit of a
struggle to describe
which is why i'm kind of repeating
myself over and over
but it makes sense when you see it
[Music]
a bunch of it is just disconnected weird
al style parody songs about things that
grind doug's gears
and the parts that are about the wall
are more often than not
so off-base that you would believe the
entire thing was created from
decades-old memories if it weren't for
the granular details that
are included it's not doug walker's
review of the wall
it's just doug walker's version of the
wall
so let's talk about some specifics
doug's parody of another brick in the
wall part two is an immediate standout
to people as just one of
the worst things they've put in their
brains that they didn't find on
rotten.com
[Music]
restyled as we need more victimization
the song is simultaneously a criticism
calling the wall whiney
engaging in bizarre what about ism and a
thinly veiled rant about online culture
war nonsense
a subject that will crop up a few times
throughout the video
most of the substance of this is
contained in doug's
inexplicable dracula impression
welcome to high school where all the
teachers are monsters
i know it looks like they want to teach
you something but they don't
they just want to eat you up because
we're evil blood [ __ ] vampire things
doug's argument here is that everyone
thinks school sucks that that opinion
isn't special or noteworthy or
substantive
that the wall is just dunking on school
because it's a popular opinion with
teenagers
and the bizarre what aboutism of
pointing out
funding issues with the america public
education system
while throwing in some stale jabs about
school teaching
algebra instead of car maintenance do
you know what we teach in these walls
how to fix a car pay your taxes ace an
interview perform first aid
manage your insurance cook healthy meals
or do household repairs
preposterous we pay other people to do
those things we teach important things
you need to know in life
like algebra
[Music]
which maybe it's the other way around i
don't know i got a high school
[Music]
now at the surface level here it just
needs to be said
doug is transparently imposing his own
experience of school
in 1980s 1990s suburban illinois
on waters experiences in primary school
in the 1950s and 60s
in england so just did a very
fundamental level this doesn't work
because it's a complete non-sequitur
it's a response to another brick in the
wall that's so
off topic that misses the mark by such a
wide mile that it's clear he just wasn't
paying attention more than that though
what interests me here is the way that
this version is an argument in support
of the status quo
like let's talk about the grim cowardice
of school helps you get a
secret plan to job sure you're more
likely to get a job when you're older
like okay let me back up a bit and
illustrate the problem here
the roots of public education are split
between two major motivators the first
being philosophical and the second
being industrial the philosophical
argument is that knowledge is inherently
valuable and it is a moral good for
society to educate everyone that a
society with a widespread familiarity
with the physical sciences mathematics
ethics literature and the arts
is a more inventive society and a more
ethical society
the industrial argument is that school
should exist
to prepare you to work this is rooted in
the real history of much of public
education as early efforts to expand
public education were driven by
industrialists whose growing empires
needed
more specialized laborers to do the work
of middle management which mostly means
accounting
the idea from their perspective was you
could convince the government to teach
everyone the reading writing and
arithmetic needed to do the job
which would make it easier to fill all
the positions needed
lower training costs and drive down the
price of math and literacy-based labor
this second argument has had a lot of
power and influence over the shape of
education in the last two centuries
and is still alive and well today there
is a tremendous amount of ongoing debate
in education circles about
the balance between raw theory and the
pragmatic
modern reality of labor there's tons of
people
who will argue that we should really
have two school tracks
so that students who just aren't that
interested in math and shakespeare who
think
algebra is useless can go watch amazon
training videos for a couple years and
get
right to work in the fulfillment
warehouse the criticism which waters is
directly engaging with in another brick
in the wall part
2 is that this arrangement school as a
pipeline to industry
means that what is taught in school and
how it is taught
will be dictated by industrialists by
corporations
the school system then becomes nothing
but a systematic
reshaping of children into ideal workers
obedient compliant and narrowly trained
in only what is needed for the job
it is a reduction of people to
exploitable labor to
uniform bricks in a wall it is critical
of the fundamental ordering of society
why should these institutions rampant
with abuse and steered by corporate
ghouls
be given so much power over us why
especially should they be given
so much power over children this is all
part of the multi-layered metaphor of
the wall
there is the autobiographical element
placed in the specifics of english
primary school in the 1950s and 60s
and the way that those experienced
shaped waters into the adult he became
which then serves as a means to
criticize the existence of the system
itself
because the abuses he suffered the
physical violence of
beating children who failed in the rote
recitation of number tables
were systematized and took place within
a system that was
at best indifferent and at worst
approving
this continues to resonate with people
to this day because
regardless of whether or not corporal
punishment has been abolished and more
idealistic pedagogies have prevailed
institutionalized school
is still an institution and will never
be
an unalloyed good it will always be
vulnerable to corruption to
abuse to manipulation and the question
of whose agenda
is served by the structure and material
must remain an eternal debate so
yeah i feel confident that doug's
argument here
just isn't very well formed it's unclear
shallow and doesn't actually engage with
the question
d-minus wait time out is this really a
world war ii
reference no it's just a bunch of kids
being hurted onto a train to a horrible
torturous building oh
yeah we're really comparing this to high
school
following we need more victimization is
an extended skit where doug
dressed as the critic defends the wall
from criticism
no no it's just meant to look weird and
creepy they're not implying
that the critic is positioned as the
rube his defenses are clearly meant to
be hollow and weak
the problem is that the accusations he's
sarcastically defending the movie
against
only hold weight based on doug's own
shallow misreading of everything else up
to this point
in the wall pink as a child hiding in a
train tunnel
sees school children as faceless blobs
crowded into cattle cars and envisions
himself
too becoming faceless this is the
beginning of the happiest days of our
lives which is effectively just the
intro to another brick in the wall part
2.
during which the faceless children are
fed into a meat grinder
so the more immediate imagery is a
slaughterhouse
is that in part or by extension also a
holocaust reference
yeah it is it is a world war ii
reference
because much of the album and movie are
about the after effects
of that war it's not an abstract concept
that's just being name-dropped for
aesthetic symmetry
it's a real event that people lived
through
and the wall is in no small part a
reflection on growing up in the shadow
of that
and reflecting on the value of it or
more specifically
the lack thereof the statement is that
the inhumanity of the system its
goals and methods are ultimately
homoousian
of the same stuff as the inhumanity that
leads a system
to load humans into cattle cars that
comparison is only
inappropriate if one you think the
message is simply school sucks
and two you've been ignoring the role of
world war
ii within the film up to this point oh
come on they're just saying school
sucks they're not making any connections
to that now let's go on to the next song
that talks about the horrors of world
war ii oh crap
see it's just a coincidence maybe
i don't know as those of you familiar
with the wall may have noticed this is
all
out of order because the joke doesn't
work if you do it in order
doug's joke is a setup for his version
of goodbye blue sky
retooled as so long weird song
is world war ii with monsters too silly
originally this is all the other way
around goodbye blue sky
leads into the train tunnel which segues
into another brick in the wall part 2.
the reason that matters is because
originally the imagery of goodbye blue
sky
is the setup for later imagery gerald
scarf's powerful visualization of the
war and specifically the blitz as a
psychological force that scarred
the collective psyche of the people as
deeply as it scarred the land and the
bodies of soldiers
like i cannot stress this enough
goodbye blue sky is one of the most
potent pieces of filmmaking i've ever
seen
it is ruinously effective at using its
imagery to convey the sheer
scale of damage and waste that the war
represents
it's grim and haunting and very
important as a foundation for what
follows
in so long weird song doug asks
if world war ii with monsters is too
silly
for a movie that also complains about
how high school bites world war
ii with monsters too silly
oh roger waters did you ever wonder why
these images of slaughter made it
in a film that also sings about how high
school
which of course again is predicated on
that
actually being the message which it
isn't and indulges in a deeply misplaced
level of literalism by describing the
sequence as
world war ii with monsters as though
this were a direct-to-video pacific rim
sequel
now this kind of literalism is a pretty
regular part of doug's normal bit
it just really falls apart here it's one
thing when it's aimed at corporate
franchise schlock aimed at kids but it
just really obviously misplaced and
inappropriate
when applied to a deeply earnest piece
of art that is
overtly symbolic unapologetically
symbolic in its attempt to communicate
what this
real event that really happened felt
like to live through
he also calls the song oscar bait which
is funny because it's both literally
wrong
goodbye blue sky wasn't eligible for an
oscar in the first place
and also because it's such a deep insult
that it's really revealing
[Music]
now i don't actually think doug was
literally calling the song oscar bait i
don't think he
thinks that they were specifically
playing towards the academy
but i do think that he thinks the wall
is spiritually oscar bait
which is to say insincere the capstone
here for me
is the replacement animation which is
first of all
just visually awful and cheap in a way
that would be considered subpar for 2007
and second is just so petty and mean
that this is what makes it very funny
when doug calls his album
a love letter to pink floyd the imperial
eagle is labeled
ego and the frightened ones are labeled
self content self-content
i honestly can't tell if that's supposed
to be content or content because neither
really makes sense i think he's saying
ego
is the destroyer of self-content like
roger waters dissatisfaction is not the
result of any real problems but is a
product of his own
ego that would parse
because the lyrics of the song do
directly address roger waters and
later a cloud labeled my problems grows
flowers of pity
and then blasts another cloud labeled
other people's problems
[Music]
i don't know i think it's one thing to
describe the wall as whiny or juvenile
to say
in effect that it encapsulates a really
teenage mindset
but it's quite another to accuse the
creators of being
disingenuous ego tripping fakes who milk
imaginary problems for pity
i don't think you can make that
accusation and then turn around
and insist that you liked it fine and
made a love letter to its creative
vision
that's the kind of thing that you say
about something you just
really don't think very highly of it all
[Applause]
[Music]
this is just such a love letter to pink
floyd's music and the wall
the song comfortably numb retooled as
comfortably dumb
is where things start to really wander
off topic
it's not really about the wall but it's
kind of about doug's relationship to the
wall
and to media in general and it's
probably
the most honest song doug put into the
project almost certainly not on purpose
nominally it's about the pacing of the
film and doug reiterates once again that
he thinks
roger's water's opinions are the
illegitimate whining of a millionaire
but it's also doug saying he doesn't
understand
and he doesn't care to the movie is
challenging and he just doesn't have
any interest in engaging with it on its
own terms
he has become comfortably dumb
[Music]
and you know what i'm not going to
disagree
you said it man i don't know if it works
as self-deprecating humor because i
don't
think it's comedically true i think it's
just true
going into the ad break there's a
changeover
so okay up to this point corey taylor
the front man for new metal band
slipknot
has been playing the equivalent role of
pink
as they transition corey is replaced
with doug
so doug plays pink for the equivalence
of in the flesh and waiting for the
worms
this is part of a running gag being that
the actual rock musician doesn't get to
sing a song until the very end at which
point he plays the spongebob squarepants
theme
and also probably just a logistical
extension of only getting corey out for
a day or two
and block shooting all of his stuff the
other thing that's going on which is
far more trivial but bothers me so much
is that the exterior shot is
overwhelmingly blue
and i'm not sure if this is a stylistic
choice or
a mistake that they just forgot to set
the white balance properly
and just left it because doug does that
just
all the time after the ad break which
consists of an uncomfortably overacted
ad for online data harvesting scam honey
and doug's own tie-in recreation of the
entire album the wall
which again they were selling for money
we get this
[Applause]
truly every frame is a painting and i'm
that nameless bow no okay
so um where do i start with this
i got some weird news for you sunshine
this was
dissing thatcher's administration
[Music]
but it's vague enough to put anyone you
fear
politicians showman just put their face
here no no doug
no it really wasn't i've got any quiz
in the audience tonight it really it
really really wasn't that vague
no one looks jewish and that was the
code
not vague at all
not even a teeny tiny bit
vague that one's looking stress he wants
to feel impressed
[Music]
okay so this whole segment is just doug
venting about people being mean to him
on twitter
it is completely disconnected from the
wall not even a tiny bit about the movie
it's just dug using the veil of alter
ego to express
an otherwise authentically held belief
and that's
honestly a charitable reading of it
because otherwise
otherwise you're saying that a criticism
of thatcherism
the policies of austerity of rigid
enforcement of christian norms
the violent suppression of political
descent of a
rising homegrown fascist movement
criticisms that
predate the aids crisis but would hold
true
well into the 80s as governments decided
it was
unofficial policy that aids was a divine
punishment and a solution to their
gay crisis you're saying that all that
isn't substantively different from
people
yelling at each other on the internet
over
batman movies
[Music]
so yeah i think the most charitable
reading here
is that doug's just talking about
himself
[Applause]
[Music]
all right there's only one major section
left and this is
maybe where i risk a controversial
opinion
common among reactions to this video is
to say that while the review as a whole
is really bad the animation at the end
is really good it's the best
part and anyone who is criticizing the
review should
you know be kind to fenna the animator
who put it all together
because it was a lot of work so
what happens is corey enters the channel
awesome office
and is about to confront doug when doug
is interrupted by a phone call
or is it just a misguided ego trip in
this self-indulgent world that we all
live in part all
who is it hello there it's sullivan
croft said oh city guy yes
actually um i was uh is lucy lacemaker
there is she there
because i was uh well it's just it's
just a thing
uh shut the [ __ ] up now
i've done all the research to piece all
this together so that i can summarize it
but
on first viewing i had zero clue
what was going on i don't know who this
is but
it's clearly a reference that the video
expects me to get
there's clearly some sort of backstory
to these characters it's not
just an abstraction and just to really
add to the confusion the whole thing is
this
mumble core overlapping ramble and it
looks like garbage and you can't
understand what they're talking about
because you
can't understand what they're even
saying not exactly giving
creation all of its credit it's not like
you just [ __ ] out the horcrux that
voldemort never meant to make
and then this thing shows up and the
barely intelligible dialogue just
keeps going until the whole thing segues
into the trial
where it honestly doesn't get much
easier to understand
[Music]
now before we get into this any further
yes there's a lot of technical
competency on display
modeling is hard texturing is hard
rigging is hard
animation is hard hair simulations are
hard all of this represents
hours and hours and hours and hours of
work
there is a lot of effort on display here
okay so fenna is a youtube animator who
makes a series called satellite city
which is
i guess a skit show with a combination
of live action and cg animation
and way way way too much lore for a
series with an average episode run time
of 130 seconds so
the characters in the trial are all
characters from satellite city
and it's it's just not good
kind of the real change of pace is that
it's not good in ways that are
new to the review so far from what i can
glean this segment was made by phenom
more or less in isolation from the rest
of the video
the track on the album is called fenn as
the trial the credits say
it's produced by fenna and so it does
seem like fenna wrote and produced
all of it using his normal stable of
voice actors
which makes sense because the opinions
are bad but
they're a different kind of bad the
entire song
is sung in universe from the viewpoint
of these characters who feel
that the wall falls short because all
the animated monsters in the movie
don't get enough screen time or
development and then
another character comes in and says that
you know
i guess we can give it a pass because it
wasn't trying to tell a story
this film's not bound by characters it's
a visual affair
it never aimed
[Music]
okay so this sucks that's just a really
weak disingenuous argument being
filtered through a character
in order to scrub it of any meaning or
ownership
because heaven forbid you put an actual
opinion out into the world
it's also just wrong at a very basic
level
the wall is telling a story it's not
conventionally told and it's a little
loose but
it's very comprehensible the animated
monsters at the end of the movie
aren't underdeveloped in the slightest
because they're extensions and
representations
of the characters that were already
present in the rest of the movie
they are psychosexual visualizations of
those
literal characters and the ideas those
characters represent
parents the state the education system
intimate partners
the problem with using fenna's horny
edgelord steampunk furry ocs
is that they actually are underdeveloped
if there's even
an attempt at using them in a
metaphorical fashion then that's lost in
the
clear specificity of the crossover
they're not present in any meaningful
capacity through the rest of the review
they don't represent anything
substantive and they are for the most
part
awful overbaked designs for one-note
characters
[Applause]
to decapitate so you're going to have
this over-designed horny rat thing
lecture about how the wall is all style
over substance devoid of intellectual
development
then alien big titty goth girlfriend
calls the movie lazy
and when i heard you were reviewing the
much to be
desired wall i figured i'll throw my own
tippins
style over substance showcasing a bunch
of weird creatures and worlds
not a drop of intellectual development
[Music]
cringe there's no other word for it this
makes me cringe
it's embarrassing on a deep level the
entire structure of this just doesn't
work
it's poor criticism and it's not even an
appropriate parallel to the segment that
it's a recreation of
if this were actually a coherent work
then this isn't where you would put the
movie on trial
this is where you would put doug on
trial this is where you would take
all the other ideas from the rest of the
review consolidate them in one place
interrogate them and interrogate what
they say about their author
so no i don't think this is the good
part of the review
because it's still a tremendous amount
of effort put into modeling texturing
and rigging a
fundamentally bad concept just at the
basics it's confusing and muddled
creatively it seems to have started from
the ending the chant
of tear down the wall taken from the
original and recontextualized to mean
tear down the wall
the movie and working backwards from
that is
just a bunch of stuff that's just
hammered into place
because if you're doing a full
recreation then you've got to put
something in there
you've got a lyric sheet to fill out in
time to kill
and of course afterwards the whole
review ends with a lazy lampshade of the
fact that the review didn't
actually contain anything of substance
okay i liked it fine yeah me too
a little full of itself but good music
and imagination fair enough
and the resolution of the gag that corey
taylor hasn't done anything yet in the
form of the spongebob squarepants theme
song
[Music]
[Applause]
kind of the buckwild thing here is that
if there were less effort put into this
if the substance was otherwise
exactly the same but there wasn't a
companion album
on sale for money there wasn't an entire
end-to-end abridged recreation if there
were just
one or two songs and a bunch of lazy
jokes about the movie being really
pretentious
then i don't think this would compel
people in the way it does
there is an effort on display that is
its own form of earnestness
and it's just all falls flat because
it's just no good
it's trying to be impressive without
being vulnerable
and simultaneous to that it's pissing on
a really earnest piece of art
specifically for being vulnerable and to
see
all this played out against the backdrop
of a movie from a band that is decades
and decades and decades old
well outside doug's normal wheelhouse
with no
clear indication of why this particular
movie
this album is something that doug feels
is worth this much effort it's a
baffling product
but wait holy crap it's long-running
character
hat dan the dan with a hat but what did
you really think about it
i guess i liked it fine a little full of
itself but they put in a lot of effort
yeah yeah
foreign